all right let's start off with media
only screen and max with 500 and my main
dot CSS file I've added media only
screen and max with 500 ok I've
refreshed the page and let's make it
smaller oh there we go as soon as it got
below 500 pixels it disappeared so that
one looks like it's working next up
we've got media only screen with max
with 500 and this orientation landscape
now orientation here is referring to
phone orientations whether it's turned
in landscape mode or portrait mode will
save main dot CSS will refresh Chrome
and let's see aha and that one's also
working now we've got media only screen
and min width 500 okay let's see
oh and as soon as i refresh the page it
disappeared that's because this screen
is bigger than 500 pixels which means
that that media query got hit and
paragraphs are being hidden last but not
least we have media only print and with
the max width of 500 now print here
means that these styles are only going
to be used if it's being printed so
we'll save the page will refresh and
here it is let's make the screen smaller
to see if it disappears and it does not
we're not printing so this paragraph is
going to stay even if the screen is
smaller than 500 pixels so looking at
the question the first one made
paragraphs disappear for screen smaller
than 500 pixels as to the second but the
third and fourth didn't